luke was mentioning intelligence
agencies and social media
and so we have this story that's been
going around from the gray zone this is
written by kit clarenberg and max
blumenthal
now you can absolutely argue these
individuals have their bias i believe
that they have a leftist bias but this
is an interesting story leaked files
expose syria psyops veteran astroturfing
bread tube star to counter covet
restriction critics
that is a mouthful of a headline now i
don't know if this is true i'm not
familiar with the gray zone take it all
with a grain of salt but they write by
covertly recruiting popular youtube
influencer abigail thorne to counter
growing opposition to uk government
covert restrictions psyops pros are
bringing home the tactics they honed in
the syrian dirty war
leaked documents have revealed a
state-sponsored influence operation
designed to undermine critics of british
of the british government's coronavirus
policies by astroturfing a prominent
founder of the bread tube click of
anti-fascist youtube influencers the
project aims to conduct psychological
profiling on british citizens dissenting
against policies such as mandatory
vaccination and lockdowns then leverage
the data to establish a youtube channel
that portrays these critics as dangerous
super spreaders of disinformation
interesting
i was accused of spreading
election disinformation and conspiracies
because one time i retweeted somebody on
twitter and they happen to have been
wrong
i don't know i don't know about the
veracity of these claims
but this is us looking through if
assuming it's all true a keyhole into
what is probably very very prominent
government agencies intelligence
operations psyops it's all real they're
all working on this stuff i was just
going to say that psyops are real the
cia has knowingly infiltrated hollywood
the corporate media politics of course
admittedly so why wouldn't you think
they would not be infiltrating the
online space of course they're doing
this and the and there's this famous
journalist udo ufc
uh he's a german journalist who
literally came out and whistleblowed he
was one of the most prominent most
important journalists in all of germany
and he said the cia came to me they they
wrote articles in my name and they told
me just to hit publish and i did many
times so the cio is what's his name udo
e-u-d-o e-u-d-o you you know that's the
first name of keti u-l-f-k-o-t-t-e
came out and said hey i was told by
intelligence agencies to regurgitate
these talking points and i did
and
uh yeah yeah so we got it we got a
wikipedia page pulled up so if they're
doing this with corporate media you
think they're not doing this with social
media obviously they are because that's
how they influence a lot of their
policies that they want to institute
luke wikipedia says he was a conspiracy
theorist yeah so that means everything
he's ever claimed is clearly false of
course wikipedia is always true no
matter what he maintained this according
to wikipedia has he maintained that
journalists including himself and
leading newspapers published material
that had been fed to them or bought by
the cia and other western intelligence
and propaganda agencies he was an
assistant editor at the german newspaper
frankfurter al-jamain zaitang
pronouncing that wrong for several years
until 2003 between 97 and his death he
authored a dozen books including a
number with populist themes
perhaps i'll tell you this i don't know
this guy i don't need to trust this guy
if you think intelligence agencies
aren't seeding stories you're the
conspiracy theorist i'm sorry you'd have
to be a conspiracy there's to believe
none of that is going on russia does it
china does it even small countries do it
small countries that we don't think
would be an issue for us they all engage
in these kind of psychological
operations and manipulations and we get
reports on here's the funny thing we get
stories where it's like
the cia said iran is engaging in
manipulation campaigns yes
why wouldn't the cia be doing the exact
same thing why wouldn't any other
intelligence agency do the exact exact
same thing in the 1970s there was
congressional hearings with members of
the cia admitting that they have agents
within all the major top news
organizations a lot of people attribute
this incorrectly to operation
mockingbird but that that's a separate
thing that's a separate issue there was
congressional hearings you could watch
the videos
of cia officials saying that they have
infiltrated
the top echelons of the corporate media
and they are using of course that power
of the corporate media in order to
spread their stories or a.k.a
disinformation but it's okay but that's
also how like a bunch of agencies
operate anyway i.e leaks from agencies
not just legal is is and to specific
media outlets the relationships between
you know bureaucrats and agencies i mean
that was that's always a problem
particularly for republican
administrators republican
administrations because the bureaucracy
is so overwhelmingly democrat but
theoretically if somebody like bernie
sanders for example were to get in as
president you would have the same
problems because the bureaucracy is sort
of uh like
technocratic neoliberal left
overwhelmingly yeah but i don't think
that that's unique to the cia we're not
talking about leaks we're not talking
about leaks we're talking about cia
agents implanted in the corporate media
i'm saying that they the stories that
you read are also seated by people in
agencies
often in service of like inter-agency
you know dispute right um what they they
allow out about the administration then
you know helps them take down somebody
in a sister organization a sister agency
that they don't like i mean this there's
a huge problem in this incestuous
relationship between media and
bureaucracy let me tell you how much
worse it is
you think it was bad back then that
intelligence agencies could get someone
from their you know division to work in
a news organization infiltrate oh
youtube facebook twitter tick tock are
going to make it so incredibly easy for
intelligence agencies to control the
narrative and control the world you have
no idea i'll make it very very simple
for you
all they need do is have access to
youtube and they simply say we want this
channel to be on the front page done so
when you have a million channels and you
have one guy who's i don't know alex
jones talking about uh all of these
crazy things some of which strangely
turned out to be true
they simply say get rid of him and then
he's gone
and then you get other channels they're
like this does advance or at the very
least doesn't interfere with
if you are advancing what they want and
pushing the narrative they want all of a
sudden your videos are appearing on the
front page of youtube you don't work for
anybody you have no handler you don't
know why
see back in the day when media
organizations were few and far between
relative to today
they needed to figure out how to seed
stories so it could be leaks it could be
over it it could be liminal it could be
super liminal or it could be subliminal
nowadays they have a million channels to
choose from and all they have to do is
be like buy ads on this channel this
person will make a bunch of money
they'll produce more content and then
we'll tell youtube to put them on the
front page then the narrative from the
intelligence agencies dominates it's
that simple absolutely and i would argue
that's potentially happening right now i
think they're putting cnn on the front
page absolutely i don't think it's
limited to intelligence agencies my
point oh for sure that it's
in operation about how to do business
i mean that's but that's the problem
right that's why we've moved so far in
terms of of um there's a ton of pressure
in these companies have a uniculture
right a monoculture for the most part
they they agree on who the bad guys and
the good guys are within the companies
and between the companies and what you
end up having is a type of sort of
cultural collusion that doesn't even
need to be like sort of communicated
right it doesn't need to be
told
most of these companies don't even need
to be told by some like shadowy official
in an administration what to do they
know who the good guys and bad guys are
they know which side of the narrative
they're on and they can implement that
without having to be told i mean i think
i know we've moved on a little bit from
the vaccine mandates but i think that's
what the the um federal mandate was i
think it was a bat signal it's probably
going to get struck down but it was a
bat signal to corporate america and most
of that enforcement has already happened
right so like it it is a way of getting
completely around the actual democratic
process of of passing laws and enforcing
them
this is why social media censorship is
such a big deal
because it's very obvious that what they
what they've been doing over the past
decade with the banning and removal of
certain certain commentators and uh
you know i guess i got to be a little
optimistic on rumble and their growth
but i'm still worried that's a
short-term solution the idea of getting
rid of
debates concepts and thinking is
absolutely absurd to say that this line
of thinking or this line of questioning
is not allowed is god like authority
that is obviously going to be abused
whether it's in the hands of susan
wozzinski or the caa it doesn't matter
that's way too much power with
infrastructure and information highways
that were funded by tax dollars with
also intelligence agencies connections
when you look at a lot of the startups a
lot of these organizations these big
tech organizations they had connections
to intelligence agencies i don't think
that was coincidental i think a lot of
these intelligence agencies saw this
coming and that's why they embedded
within them they're working hand in hand
with them and i think they're using this
to promote this as you mentioned him in
many covert ways where we don't even
realize that they're doing it and it and
it might not even be that as obvious as
it used to be where they had an agent
within cbs news they don't have to do
that anymore they just have to control
the algorithm which i think they have a
lot of sway in
at the very least you can take a look at
how youtube operates and
we often have some of our segments it's
very obvious some just are shadow banned
some aren't
we uh for a while they had all these
channels in an isolation bubble where
they stopped recommending them to any uh
outside channel so it's like if you were
all it was a clever way to to destroy
anti-establishment opinions if you were
in this group of people they segmented
you away from all the mainstream youtube
content so no you were no longer
recommended but if you were already
subscribed to these channels you'd be
recommended only those channels then
over time they shrink out those channels
shut some down give them strikes and
then they're gone
and then it pushes to the mainstream
narrative now you go on look this all
you gotta do you to understand this get
a brand new computer or open a private
tab and go to youtube.com and look at
what they promote to people now um to be
honest
it's family-friendly stuff they're
trying to make an entertainment channel
like get it but you are not you will see
leftist political commentary you will
see jimmy kimmel making political
commentary about trump or whatever even
though it's trump's not the president
but you're not going to get the inverse
cnn cbs all of these news outlets will
be put on the front page and then what
do they do well people were disliking
them and it was strange how is this on
the front page if nobody likes it so
then what youtube what did youtube do
they got rid of the dislike button
that's how you do that's how you control
the narrative yep you also go on the
trending page that also tells you a lot
of what ideas and videos are being
promoted to you compared to of course
the actual videos that are getting the
views they don't show you that anymore
they used to that's how they got
everyone hooked in look at the front
page of reddit also another
huge change that was happening very
subtly
not overtly but but i think slowly and
surely it just became an absolute crap
show and they did it by slowly boiling
the water on reddit and making it more
and more progressive making it more and
more just absolutely insane as time went
on just like with uh ebay and the color
yellow which tim explains a lot where
people didn't like the color yellow but
they slowly changed no they didn't like
white
the website was yellow they changed it
overnight to white and everyone
complained like ah it hurts i don't want
to see it so they changed it back and
then every day they slowly made it white
until a year later it was white nobody
cared and i think that's also happening
with our kind of consciousness and the
information that we're getting from a
lot of these big tech platforms that are
only getting crazier and crazier and
crazier by the day and i think that's
exemplified with people getting crazy
and also us dealing with a mental health
crisis that we never ever had before
when it came to the onset of social
media yeah the the great jordan peterson
broke that down in an interview at some
point in time or he was just like if i
shove you you're gonna fight back but
what i have to do is just kind of take
an inch towards you and then another
inch another inch and then before you
know it i pushed you wherever i wanted
you to go to begin with without having
to take the measure of shoving you yep i
think the most important thing when
you're thinking about
you know how
tech companies and how social media
manipulate what's seen and what isn't is
that
we need to build new networks from
scratch and whatever reliance anyone has
on any of these networks um
it's any of these companies you have to
operate on the assumption that
eventually you'll get banned
and you have to build in advance and
think about it in advance and build
these networks and new and look there
are major consequences to having a red
and blue everything right ideally we
would not have like a red and blue
coffee shop a red and blue you know
server provider like
red and blue internet right um but i
don't see any alternative because there
isn't going to be and the line is moving
extremely fast in terms of like
initially of course some of the most
disturbing things that i saw when it
jumps away from social media and into
real life because some people just with
some legitimacy say like okay well you
don't have a right to a twitter account
you don't have a right to a youtube
account
that's true
but when every network bans you right
every company bans you there's a certain
um you know inability to get your
message out but even moving beyond that
they have jumped it into irl right so
where you can't get a bank account maybe
you can't use private transit like uber
and lyft right there's obviously a
problem um and actually i mean this this
i get a little flat a lot of flack for
making this comparison but not on the
substance of it but on the like shape of
the problem it starts to look very much
like what the 1964 civil rights act was
put in place to solve right because the
problem wasn't that one restaurant was
not serving black americans the problem
is that every restaurant in an entire
geographic area and every hotel and
every service was not willing to serve a
class of customer because they had a a
predetermined cultural agreement that
didn't wasn't you know quote unquote
traditional antitrust right because
they're not talking to each other saying
we're freezing people out there was a
cultural a modern culture a cultural
agreement not to serve certain customers
the the shape of what's happening now i
think is is quite similar
yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you